[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut être une prestation
gênante faut remédier au genoa ce que ça
prouve que les chanteurs chantent en
direct pour vrai il est interdit de
jouer d'un instrument de musique c'est
vrai c'est dans les règlements tout et
sur bande musicale pour ce qui est des
musiques mais on chante bel et bien en
direct et mcdonald's a prouvé hier ils
ont avec une interprétation assez égale
d'un mélange de deux chansons de
chansons que l'on reconnaît bien là que
preier une nouvelle chanson futur qui
est le dévoilé hier et qui va se
retrouver sur son prochain album qui va
être lancée le 14 juin et en talent de
ces fausses notes par tous oui
effectivement parce que c'est absolument
évident à elle n'était pas
particulièrement en forme vocale mayer
comme quelques représentants de quelques
piques el massa arrive à l'eurovision
mais on se demandait est ce qu elle l ai
parlé donc du conflit israélo
palestinien
roger waters membre fondateur de pink
floyd lui lui avait demandé karima
d'annuler sa participation pour appuyer
les palestiniens elle lui avait répondu
non je fais de la musique pour tout le
monde et c'est le message qu'il a répété
hier musique au musée
[Applaudissements]
je crois même sa musique
mexes de pippo créateur c'est du pur
madonna qui se s'est elle-même un de ses
succès semble usée donc on se demandait
ce qu'il y aura des coups d'éclat des
moments scandaleux et pas vraiment il ya
eu quelques petits moments où il ya eu
des références à la palestine il ya eu
un moment où les animateurs de france 2
mais ça les a rendus très mal à l'aise
lorsque le groupe islandais
atari a reçu ses notes on savait que
d'autres voulaient parler de ça et de la
navigation dans les médias et voici ce
qui s'est passé avec six points
[Applaudissements]
assiste-t-on hué par le public
évidemment s ils ont sorti les drapeaux
et du spa politique à l'eurovision c'est
la règle pas de politique à l'eurovision
donc l on ait rappelé les règles
à ce moment là qu'un pointage par payer
et ce sont les pays bas qui est qu'ils
ont remportée après des décennies cela
faisait quarante quatre ans que les pays
bas n'avaient pas gagné l'eurovision
cinquième fois que le pays remportait
etc donnent qu'une lorraine qui revient
avec la palme
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
les parieurs lui donnait près de 50% des
chances de gagner et 6 s'est passé il
avait participé à l'émission la voix ou
aux pays-bas en 2014 il avait été
éliminé juste avant la finale là il
s'est bel et bien rendu en finale et la
gagner et donc une chanson qui lui a été
inspiré par l'histoire de quelqu'un qui
l'a profondément aimés et qui est mort
jeune pour ce qui est de la france on
suit ça chaque année
ça fait depuis 1977 que la france n'a
pas gagné c'est bill al hassani qui
représentait la france
il a terminé au 14e rang
[Musique]
je suis
et donc ça veut dire que la france a
moins bien fait que l'année dernière
l'année dernière le duo madame monsieur
avait réussi à obtenir le 13e rang la
14e rang il faut dire que c'est le duo
de l'année dernière qui a écrit la
chanson qui a été interprété cette année
il ya peut-être un message là en bref
peut-être faire appel à d'autres
contrôles buts et auteur la surprise
hier soir c'est qu'on a vu on ne savait
pas une chanteuse née et qui a grandi à
montréal représentait la grèce
elles sont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle s'appelle catherine dos cas elle
est née à montréal elle a grandi ici de
parents grecs
adolescente elle est allée habiter en
grèce avec ses parents elle habite à
athènes elle a obtenu un contrat de
disque en 2015 elle a sorti un premier
album cette année là il ya un deuxième
album qui est en préparation
elle a terminé malheureusement au 21e
merci pour cette tournée musicale refait
mondiale